[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima on Monday
night's episode of The Bachelorette
viewers witnessed one of the most
heartbreaking hometown visits in the
history of the franchise it was a new
mother died watch your sub eating lunch
or shrivel just to see her gets smaller
and smaller audiences watched as
contestant Dean saw his father in person
for the first time in years addressing
how rough their relationship had been
since Dean's mother died when he was
just 15 none of us came together and I
came into like a moment of solidarity
and be like hey like this sucks for all
of us like let's be with each other and
like let's build off of this and after
all that adding on to Dean's pain even
more even though she had told him she
was practically falling in love with him
Rachel sent him home I wonder if like
you're really ready for the same things
that I'm ready for when it comes to the
next step of things
that leaves Peter Eric and Brian as
Rachel Lindsey's final three and they'll
all head to Spain I actually spoke to
Rachel earlier on Monday and she told me
what her biggest fears were about Peter
and Brian after hometowns with Peter
it's pretty obvious is he ready does he
want the same things that I want I
didn't come here for a boyfriend and
with Brian do I trust his sincerity so
what do you guys think of Rachel sending
Dean home and who do you think she'll
pick in the end let me know over on
Twitter
[Music]